hier on n'a pas fait seulement la fête
dans la capitale mais partout en ile de
france tout le monde a communié dans la
même fièvre et dans la même passion pour
le football pour l'équipe de france et
pour la victoire
marianne puissant emmanuel hunzinger ont
passé la soirée avec quelques supporters
dans la cité des francs moisins à saint
denis
reportage hier soir c'était soirée foot
au bâtiment 5 des francs moisins pour
l'occasion comme a invité ses copines et
quelques voisines les garçons étaient
les bienvenues mais ce soir ils sont en
minorité sur quel côté gauche
lizarazu sur l'arrière conte à l'abri du
vial mais ils ont déjà
goûter la joie de la coupe du monde
alors moi j'aimerais bien que les autres
tous un petit peu aussi la joie
ce sera donc une finale entre filles
attention c'est parti pour l'ambiance
mais aussi
marthe est il bien
m
100 de la première mi temps c'est tout
le quartier qui se réveille à 300 mètres
du stade les francs moisins exulte
bon le troisième de troisième
et à l'heure du thé à la menthe ou me la
tend ce troisième but sur un plateau
on ne la coupe c'est fini mais si tu
veux demain pour nous la france ici
hassani personnellement ou la france
entière la vie commence c'est la
première fois qu'on gagne la coupe on
rentre dans l'histoire c'est vraiment
génial